It is a very ambitious script
and we wanted to do so much in so little time and we really set the bar high so to do a job like
this and really test the camera and test what you can do. It's just fantastic. So, of course we have to do it.
It's a big camera
so it needs to fit, but I think we've been, you know, designing the sets in exactly the way we want them.
Getting to experience, you know of this kind of format and this kind of shooting it's difficult to go back
Action!
Slow 10% down the pace
We start, you know in this limited frame and then we open up
That little frame within the frame is regular format, and then when you passed that frame
that's the change you go from one world to another
from real to unreal
That's the feeling I get when you look through the camera
Three, two, one. Go!
The screen is so big and you really want to create an immersive experience.
And then she's just gonna fall over and she can just move a little bit
Feeling that canvas and those atmospheric elements to make it as rich and intriguing as possible
There's a lot of pulse involved in this film, but I have to say I think it's really fun, when we get it on camera
and, Action!
Because it's instant gratification
The sound is so important because it makes the world surround you
a truly enhanced experience
Action!
Watching movies in IMAX is just a greatest experience
There is it's magic, you know, it will take you somewhere else, it will transport you to different worlds
And IMAX is the best place to experience that.
You